[Music]
we're doing an issue on inspirational
people Oh
mr. Rogers hello neighbor the beloved
children's television host so good to
see you again today
you hired me as an investigative
journalist I don't do puff pieces 400
words play nice mr. Rogers I'm here to
interview you it is so nice to meet you
this piece will be for an issue about
heroes do you consider yourself a hero
not at all
I insisted he read you before we agreed
and did he every article we could find
okay profiling mr. majors on our program
I tried to look through the camera into
the eyes of a single child it's just
about the nicest person I've ever met I
just don't know if he's for real
Boyd please come on my child all these
people line up to tell you their
problems that would be an internal
burden on you sometimes we have to ask
for help
and that's okay you love broken people
like me I don't think we were broken
[Music]
you need to let people know that each
one of them is precious roll sound
Daniel you said I'm said Thank You
Daniel did you just talk to the puppet
please I'm talking
you